hi it's michelle of lab muffin beauty science
chemistry phd cosmetic chemist and owner of
a terrible teenage skincare routine i talked about
my teenage skincare routine before go watch that
if you want all the gory details i have
oily acne prone and dehydration prone skin
and that skincare routine
made everything so much worse
it took me about 15 years to figure out a good
skincare routine we didn't have as much skin
care info on the internet back then so
today i'm going to be talking about the
skincare routine that i wish i had if i was a
teenager again i've included a few alternatives
for different skin types and i've tried to
keep everything below 20 australian dollars
i have included a few things that tend to go on
sale a lot and with overseas products the prices
tend to fluctuate a bit and remember these are
my recommendations they might not work for you
if you have other products that work really
well for you share them in the comments
make sure you like and subscribe if
you like science-based beauty content
i'm going to start with a thing not to have in
your routine and that is a mirror and tweezers
where you do homework i have a few dented scars in
my nose here and between my eyebrows around here
if you look closely and those are from digging
blackheads out of my face when i was 14. it is
just too easy to procrastinate by picking out your
skin if you have a mirror in the place where you
tend to procrastinate the most and a magnifying
mirror is even worse do not get a magnifying
mirror if someone gives you a magnifying mirror it
is a curse re-gift it to a cousin you don't like
so let's go on to cleansers cleansing is important
and gentle cleansers are the way to go clogged
pores are one of the things that you start having
to deal with when you reach your teenage years
unless you're one of those genetically
blessed people with no skin issues ever
and that is because sebum which is
your skin oil is actually one of the
things that clogs your pores sometimes
your body is just not a team player
one of the big components of sebum is
squalene which is also a skincare ingredient
this reacts with oxygen and in light and
it goes from runny to sticky and more solid
so this starts sticking dead skin cells together
to form little plugs in your skin that clog your
pores and these are called microcomedones so
cleansing reduces the amount of sebum on your face
and gets rid of some of the stuff that's already
reacted and so that helps to reduce clogged pores
another good reason to use a cleanser
is really just the feel cleansers get
dirt and oil off your skin as well as any
skincare or makeup products that you're using
i talk a lot more about choosing and using a
good cleanser in my ebook the lab muffin guide
to basic skincare but in short stripping your
skin with cleansing is not a good approach you
can't just bully your skin into behaving it makes
oily skin feel worse and it irritates your skin
if you have acne prone skin that's even worse
because irritation is one of the factors that
contributes to acne along with oil and lots
of dead skin cells which i mentioned before
cleansers with high ph can also disturb your skin
and make it easier for acne bacteria to spread and
really get ingrained into your skin anyway i think
a lot of people especially people who are new to
skin care tend to underestimate how important
a good cleanser is because they wash off so it
seems like it doesn't have that much of an impact
it's only on your skin for a short amount of time
but in reality a good cleanser
can make a massive difference
so here are my picks for budget friendly
cleansers that work well for acne prone skin
a disclaimer this video isn't sponsored but i've
been sponsored by some of these brands in the past
and i was sent samples of a lot of these
products but these are my genuine recommendations
i really like the bioderma cleansing gels
they come in handy pumped tops and they just
work really well the bioderma sebium cleansing
gel is specifically made for acne prone skin
it can be a little stripping if your skin is
dehydration prone so these days i actually
prefer the sensibio gel cleanser this is a
bit more hydrating but it is missing some of
the actives that the sebium cleanser has
that can help with oily acne prone skin
another of my favorites that you can get in stores
in australia is the bondi sands fresh'n up gel
cleanser this is also launching worldwide it's
really gentle fragrance free and very no frills
the harder labo gokujyun cleanser and the
heimish all clean green foam are also really
gentle very similar sort of idea but they
foam a bit more a few more supermarket picks
the neutrogena ultra gentle daily cleanser
the cetaphil oily skin cleanser the cerave
hydrating cleanser and the avene cleanance
gel if you're australian and you're after an
in-store option i'd also check out the azclear
foaming cleanser and the qv gentle skin cleanser
so cleansing you should probably do this about
once or twice a day how much you want to cleanse
really depends on your skin i've personally found
that cleansing once a day at night is a lot better
than cleansing twice a day because my skin is so
dehydration prone cleansing too much just tends
to dry it out but that might be different for you
just feel free to experiment with the frequency
okay onto makeup removal now i wasn't allowed to
wear makeup to school so i didn't really need this
but these days i love doing a double cleanse i
didn't know what that was back then basically
cleansing oils and cleansing balms are products
that you can use to melt away makeup really easily
and they also work really well for water resistant
sunscreen it just sort of gets rid of everything
before you go in with another cleanser now the
annoying thing with cleansing oils is that they
can be a bit expensive and difficult to find
the one that was easiest to find was the simple
kind to skin cleansing oil but unfortunately
it looks like it's been discontinued there
is the qv bath oil in australia which wasn't
made to be a cleansing oil but it works pretty
well for that it does leave behind a bit of
residue though so you'll want to follow up with
a regular cleanser the korean brand etude house
also has cleansing oils that sometimes go on sale
cleansing balms are solid versions that are a
bit easier to use but they also tend to be a
bit expensive the cheapest options that i've tried
and loved are the ordinary squalane cleanser and
the heimish all clean balm if you're looking for
a simpler cleansing routine and you wear makeup
or waterproof sunscreen i would recommend a
micellar water you can use this as a single
product to remove makeup and clean your skin
simple have a really good budget-friendly micellar
water bioderma is also fantastic i'd recommend the
sensibio one over the sebium because you can't use
the sebium around your eyes both of these have
been through a lot of clinical testing to make
sure they're really gentle and they can be left
on skin without rinsing for most people without
issues so it's really good for after sports
or if you're just too tired to get to a sink
i'd also grab some reusable
cotton pads to use with these
cheaper disposable cotton pads tend to be a
bit rough on skin i actually used to use some
that made me think that the micellar water
was too harsh for my skin for a long time
and yeah i'm not really that smart i just
play a smart person on tv most brands of
reusable cotton pads last for ages you can
also make some diy ones if you're a bit crafty
now on to acne treatments there are a few common
over-the-counter options that are good for dealing
with acne but it's important to remember as dr
anjali mahto said in our collaboration on food
and acne if you've given these over-the-counter
options a good bash and your acne doesn't seem to
be getting better and this is an option that's
available to you it is a good idea to talk to
a doctor or dermatologist sometimes
what looks like acne is something else
sometimes acne comes from internal causes that
over-the-counter products just can't really fix
if your acne is extending onto the rest of your
body if it's starting to scar or affect your
mental health these are good signs that you
should probably move on to professional help
let's start with the most famous acne ingredient
benzoyl peroxide it is famous for a good reason
it is really effective at killing acne bacteria
and it does it in a way that doesn't promote
bacterial resistance in other words as you're
attacking the bacteria the bacteria doesn't just
evolve and get even stronger which is not a good
situation benzoyl peroxide also decreases clogged
pores so it deals with baby pimples that haven't
become full-blown pimples yet it is pretty harsh
and drying though so you'll probably need
a gentle cleanser and a good moisturizer
and it does tend to work better when you
use it all over your face preventatively
rather than as a spot treatment after the pimple
has already well and truly left the station
my favorite type of benzoyl peroxide product is
a benzoyl peroxide cleanser benzoyl peroxide is
really annoying because it does tend to stain
things it bleaches stuff it reacts with dyes
and fabric and it tends to wander off your face
onto things that you really want to stay coloured
so things like pillowcases and towels and shirts
be really careful about what you're using when
you start using benzoyl peroxide because chances
are your favorite shirt is going to get ruined
having the benzoyl peroxide in a cleanser means
that most of it will go down the drain before that
happens but it is best to just be a bit careful
wear some old clothes at first if you're using a
benzoyl peroxide cleanser i would recommend that
you also have a gentle cleanser as well because
you probably don't want to use the benzoyl
peroxide every day because yeah it can really dry
out your skin some popular options are benzac ac
wash which has 5% benzoyl peroxide and neutrogena
clear pore cleanser mask which has 3.5% when you
use these you want to apply it to your face and
then wait about a minute before you wash it
away so that that benzoyl peroxide has time
to sink into your skin and work these benzoyl
peroxide cleansers are also really handy if you
have acne on your body so you can avoid stains
on your clothes it can also act as a deodorant if
you use it on your armpits because it kills the
bacteria in your armpits that causes the stank
if you want to use a leave-on benzoyl peroxide
product there's research showing that 2.5%
works as well as 10% with less irritation so go
for the lower percentage don't get sucked in
by the higher number and remember to put it on
all over so that it prevents future pimples
prevention is a lot easier than treatment
the second ingredient i recommend for acne is
salicylic acid this is also known as beta hydroxy
acid and it acts as an exfoliant it helps your
dead skin cells shed more evenly and that means
it prevents clogged pores and blackheads it keeps
your pores clearer and so they look less obvious
generally chemical exfoliants will just smooth
out your skin a bit it will reduce some of that
skin texture now the problem with salicylic
acid products is that a lot of the good ones
tend to be a bit more expensive 0.5 to 2% is a
good concentration for most people the cheapest
product i could find is the revolution skincare
2% salicylic acid toner which is $20 for a 200
mL bottle my favorite one actually isn't too bad
it's the paula's choice one which comes in a mini
30 mL bottle for $15 which is surprisingly
cheaper than the inkey list and revolution
30 mL ones for australians at least and i think
it is just a much better formula alternatively
you could get the 118 mL bottle for $42 which
works out to be about one-third cheaper per ml
the way i use this is i pour a little bit into
my hand and then i spread it all over my face
with my fingers you can also just rub your hands
together and then press it into your skin as well
some people like to apply these with a cotton
pad but to me it feels like i am wasting product
there is also azelaic acid azelaic acid isn't my
favorite ingredient it seems to work for a lot
of conditions according to studies but it also
just doesn't really seem to be super effective
at any one thing and the texture of azelaic acid
products is kind of tacky and thick and gloopy
but azelaic acid is generally less
irritating than a lot of other active
ingredients so i thought i'd mention it two
options in australia are azclear and finacea
i do also want to mention alpha hydroxy
acids even though you have an exfoliant
in the beta hydroxy acid the salicylic acid i've
personally found that with texture and whiteheads
alpha hydroxy acids tend to work a
lot better my budget-friendly picks
for this would be the ordinary's glycolic
acid toner which is a little bit strong
it is a bit spicy on a lot of people's skin so be
careful with this don't use it every day maybe mix
it in with something else so you don't use as much
there's also the ordinary's lactic acid products
these are a bit gentler lactic acid in general
is a bit gentler than glycolic acid because
the molecules are larger so they
don't get into the skin as deeply
onto a product that i really wish i knew about
when i was in high school hydrocolloid pimple
patches these are little stickers that you stick
onto pimples and they soak up the liquid and
pus inside the pimples i've personally found that
they seem to work a little bit better on inflamed
pimples you can also use them over intact pimples
but i personally feel like they work better
after i've stabbed the pimple with a sterile lance
i'm not sure if that's just me being superstitious
and i feel like there's a tunnel so the liquid can
get out better but i have another video on how to
pop a pimple safely so check that out if you tend
to pop your pimples and you can't really stop
the main thing i like about these pimple
patches is that they stop you from picking
out your pimples any further plus sealing in the
moisture helps them heal a bit faster the most
budget-friendly option is to buy something like
a duoderm bandage and cut it up into little bits
they can be a bit chunky though and they can
just sort of leap off your face at awkward
moments if you move around too much like in the
middle of a sentence so you probably only want
to use these at nighttime or if you're at home
and you're not really seeing anyone there are
also flatter versions that are specifically made
for pimples and these are great because you can
wear them during the day and they're not super
obvious if your skin is raw it's really hard
to get makeup and concealer to sit on it properly
so if you have the right color patch it disguises
the pimple so it's a lot less noticeable you
can also just go completely the other way and
use the pimple patches that look like stars if
that's more your style cosrx have some really
cheap ones there's also hero cosmetics who have
mighty patch and one of the versions has tapered
edges which makes it blend in really nicely on
your face i think most countries also have local
versions of these pimple patches in australia
there's the very originally named pimple patch
we are a simple people here so remember if you've
tried a few options and it didn't really help or
if your acne is quite severe and causing scarring
go see a doctor you can also do this if you just
want to skip all this trial and error and cut
straight to the higher risk higher reward options
now sunscreen if you've been on the internet you
will probably know that every skin care person
says sunscreen is super important and it is it's
really important for protecting your skin from uv
uv is linked to skin cancer and premature aging
the uv can break down collagen which is what keeps
your skin bouncy so it's a good idea to get
into the habit of wearing sunscreen every day
if you're going out into the sun for acne
prone skin sunscreen is especially good for
preventing post inflammatory hyperpigmentation
this is where after your skin's been traumatized
such as after a pimple it starts to
just pump out extra brown pigment
and so you get this little patch of brown you
get a little dark spot and this can take months
to go away this happens more if you have melanated
skin that is used to being good at producing brown
pigment the problem is that it can be hard to get
into the habit of wearing sunscreen daily a lot of
sunscreens feel heavy and greasy so if you haven't
used a lot of skincare before then this can be
a lot to adjust to so the best sunscreen for you
is the sunscreen that you'll wear consistently and
at the right amount and lots of studies have shown
that the nicer the texture of a sunscreen the more
likely it is that you'll wear it consistently so
generally what you're looking for in a sunscreen
is firstly a suitable spf rating generally over
30 is recommended and the higher the number the
more protection you get if the amount of uv isn't
that high where you are spf 15 might be enough you
also want good uva protection uva is a type of uv
that's more strongly linked to hyperpigmentation
to get good uva protection it's a bit
more confusing because depending on where
in the world you are it's labeled
differently so you're looking for
broad spectrum or the uva circle
logo or pa with three or four pluses
or a high ppd number or more stars in the boots
star rating i have a lot of other videos about
sunscreens if you want more details on how to
choose and use them but here are some popular
budget-friendly lightweight sunscreens that
might help you start on your sunscreen journey
biore skin aqua watery essence is a japanese
sunscreen that's sold in a lot of online stores
that ship to lots of countries it's super popular
and works for a lot of people because it has such
a lightweight refreshing feel
and it sits well under makeup
it's designed to feel watery bondi sands fragrance
free lotion is a cheaper option that's not quite
as lightweight but it's available in lots of
countries including the us uk and australia
there's a body and a face version and most people
seem to agree that they feel pretty much the same
it also has four hours water resistance
so you can use it for beach days as well
if you're in australia i'd also recommend
trying the two dollar sunscreens that you
can get in woolworths and coles and aldi these
are meant to be body sunscreens but they're
actually quite nice in texture and they're
super budget friendly so if they don't work
for your face they should be fine for your
body they're also four hours water resistant
the natio daily defence and the cancer
council matte face are also really
popular australian sunscreens
they work well under makeup but
some people do complain about their
eyes stinging a bit with these
so with application the amount you want to
apply is about a quarter teaspoon for your face
or two generous ish finger lengths of sunscreen
more is more when it comes to sunscreen the
more you use the better the protection you have
so don't skimp on sunscreen don't mix it with
anything apply it generously don't forget to
reapply it if you're getting more sun exposure
these things are usually written on the label
as well so check that for specific instructions
and don't forget there are other ways you
can also protect yourself from the sun
don't stay in the sun for too long wear some
protective clothing like hats and sunglasses
now on to moisturizers i have personally
never really had a good time with the standard
super budget-friendly bulk moisturizers
that a lot of people tend to recommend
i'm talking about things like cerave cetaphil
and qv which is like the australian version of
these and just sorbolene cream these tend to come
in really big pump bottles or in really big tubs
they do work for a lot of people so i'd recommend
giving them a try especially if you have drier
skin or if you live in a cool dry climate but for
me these tend to feel a bit greasy they feel like
they're sitting on the surface of my skin and
not really sinking in and they clog my pores
so if you've tried these and you don't like
them but you still feel like your skin needs
a moisturizer here are some lighter
options it's actually a bit difficult
to find lighter moisturizers that still
hydrate well from western drugstore brands
but bondi sands recently launched two moisturizers
that are really lightweight and hydrating
they're also fragrance free neutrogena hydro
boost also has moisturizers that are really
good options but they are fragranced which can
be a problem if you're sensitive to fragrance
asian skincare brands tend to have really good
lightweight moisturizers but there are very few
of them that are consistently below 20 australian
dollars one that i've tried and seems to work for
a lot of people and stays around the $20 mark is
the iunik cintella calming cream this has centella
which is great for soothing irritated skin you can
also try slugging if you want this is where you
put a thick layer of vaseline over your face while
you sleep so you can live the slug life i'd be
a little cautious about this for acne prone skin
because while petroleum jelly by itself isn't very
good at clogging your pores it can potentially
help your other products irritate more so proceed
with caution but it is a very cheap thing to
try that can work really well for dry weather
now if you're a bit of a skin picker like i was
when i was a teenager and i still am sometimes
i'd also recommend the la roche posay cicaplast
baume b5 this is a really nice hydrating almost
ointment like thick cream that's really good for
protecting your skin when it's raw and peeling
i used to pick off flakes of skin with tweezers
and i'd end up with these raw patches of skin
on my face and this just really calms that sort
of thing down a cheap alternative for this is
again vaseline i don't find that it works quite as
well because it doesn't have those extra actives
so i've linked all of these budget-friendly
recommendations in the description i've also
linked a few other videos that you might be
interested in there's one on hyperpigmentation
and how to deal with it especially those dark post
acne marks if there are some really great products
that i've missed let me know in the comments
also like and subscribe you can follow me on
instagram and tiktok and check out my blog and
i will see you next time for more beauty science